Now with that in mind, I've given you the template of most of the the fillin function,
and I want you to just put in two missing pieces.
What does the fillin function do?
First, it finds all the letters in the formula, and I want you to fill in that piece.
Then it iterates a collection called the digits, a permutation of the digits
taken from all the digits n at a time, and you have to fill in the right value of n.
Then it builds a table from taking the letters.
That means you want to make sure that the letters up here are represented
as a string and not as some other type of collection.
It makes a translation table from the letters
and a string of all the digits that we got out of the permutations.
The function itertools.permutations returns a tuple of results,
and so we want to join together that tuple into one big string,
make up the translation table, and then call formula with the translate method
with that table to translate all the letters into the appropriate digits and yield that result.
In other words, fillin is a generator function not a function that returns a list of results.
Why did I do it that way? Well, because you might get lucky.
It might be that the very first formula you try or one of the few
first formulas you try is the correct one.
If I do for f in fillin a formula, I ask for the first formula, and if it is valid,
then I want to return it right away.
I don't want to waste time calculating all the other possible fillins.
That's why a generator makes more sense here.
See if you can fill in these two missing pieces.